so we're going to go through some
information to get started first we'd
like to start by thanking our sponsors
numb focus sponsors the meetup group
itself TD Ameritrade provides this
wonderful venue for us to gather and the
- institution at Michigan sponsors the
dinner so if you know someone from these
organizations please say thank you for
supporting our group a few important
points we have emergency exits there's
one exit here as you exit there's an
there's a stairwell just to your right
most importantly just don't use the
elevator in order to get out in the case
of an emergency
feedback we're always looking for
feedback positive or negative or ideas
for how to improve the group so if you
have any feedback you can get that to us
in multiple ways you can tell one of the
organizers or you can follow us on
twitter at pi data and harbor or email
us at the address here and also this is
a borrowed space so please be sure to
clean up after yourself and gather all
your trash and take it back to the
kitchen area so after the presentation
today we will have a short Q&A session
just to set some expectations generally
unless you're you have a question
throughout the presentation that's
really a short trying to save it till
the end and then at the end please
phrase your questions as a question and
we just want the Q&A to sort of like
move quickly so keep your questions for
30 seconds or less
if you have longer things that you like
to discuss then we can sort of self
organize after the Q&A for discussions
after we've concluded as a larger group
so pi data has a code of conduct which
I'll read now
hygena is dedicated to providing a
harassment for you needing experience
for everyone regardless of gender sexual
orientation gender identity and
expression disability physical
appearance body size race or religion we
do not tolerate harassment of many
participants in any form all
communication should be appropriate for
a professional audience including people
of many different backgrounds sexual
language and imagery is not appropriate
for any of our meet-up events be kind to
others do not insult or put-down other
attendees behave professionally remember
that harassment and sexist racist or
exclusionary jokes are not appropriate
for pi data attendees violating these
rules may be asked to leave the Meetup
at the sole discretion of the meetup
organizers so thank you for making this
welcoming friendly event for everyone so
to get things moving we're gonna do a
quick icebreaker with Sean allowed me to
come up with so everyone turn to your
neighbor and tell them a statistic that
you heard over the holiday break and
whether or not you think it's true
[Music]
the shower my
and continue networking and meeting
everyone after the talk is over we like
to do a little nod to the current events
of data science so this market data
science Shawn pointed out that flare is
now available this is developed by the
Lando research and this is a powerful
NLP library built on top of Pi core so
if you're interested in doing natural
language processing you might be
interested in looking into this school
and we also want you to make you aware
of our next meetup event which will be
Wednesday February 6 by Helen Odom who
is from TD Ameritrade and she'll be
talking about privacy isn't dead which
should be really interesting so that's
already available online so sign up and
reserve your spot for that okay and
lastly now we have some time for
community announcements so if there is
any activities going on in the area or
if anyone is looking to hire or looking
for new job opportunities now's an
opportunity to speak up to the group and
make everyone aware with that so anyone
want to share something with the group
I guess I'll mentioned that the PyCon
conference is in Cleveland I think at
the end of April and that's something
that you all might be interested in it's
about a week long its combination of
talks and tutorials and it's extremely
affordable
I think the registration is like five
hundred dollars for the entire thing if
you're an academic or a student it's
only a hundred dollars so you might
consider looking at a hike on and it's
driving distance from here Thanks anyone
else and if you're looking for jobs you
know you can say it now or just just
sort of socialize that this is a great
place to find new opportunities I've one
announcement in case anybody missed it I
github just as is now offering a
completely free private repos so if
you're not part of a university and
you've been paying for private
repositories like I did I can't I went
out to the free level today so just a
heads up Wow sometimes you told me that
I've been having my students create all
the repos because Michigan students get
free Fiverr is those they own everything
all right so now we'll move with the
talk our speaker today today is claire
roberts thompson and she works at trace
which is a california-based startup that
works on making youth sports videos
hassle-free so Claire works on combining
and processing data from video and other
sensors and traces current products
include an easy-to-use application for
coaching player development and
recruiting English soccer and one thing
that I love about Claire is that she has
she did her degree at Harvard College
with a major in math and a minor in
physics which is my field
so now let's welcome Claire okay thanks
Patricia for the kind introduction so
today we're going to take an object in
sorry today we're going to take a
journey into object tracking in sports
and I'll also tell you a little bit
about my journey into object tracking in
sports as well as the work that I do at
trace so for tonight our objective is
going to be to build a robust object
tracker specifically to track athletes
during a soccer game so what does this
mean and we're going to be talking about
object tracking or analyzing video to
understand how objects move so their
location their identity and we want to
specifically analyze video of a soccer
game to understand how athletes move
around the field so we'll be talking
about things like video computer vision
related topics like object detection
object tracking data more generally
sensors GPS accelerometer other senses
to Python and you're glad you're at a PI
da to read up okay so the first question
that I usually ask when I have someone
suggest I built something is what what
do I have to work with what dollar do I
have what tools do I have and I'll also
talk of it here about how did we get
here how did I get here so I work for
trace it's a small company we have about
22 people and staff it's a small
engineering team we have nine engineers
who do a variety of hardware software
web mobile backend all kinds of things
trace is a start-up we've been around
for seven to eight years but we're still
operating in start-up mode we're based
in California I work remotely here in
Ann Arbor out of our friendly local
co-working space work and tile over on
Main Street
so at race we we build products for a
general audience so we're looking at
folks who enjoy what they do who engage
in their sport regularly but aren't
necessarily professionals and we focus
on keeping products simple and easy to
use not everyone has a technical
background you know people are primarily
interested in their sport that's that's
why they're using our products and
throughout the companies sort of
trajectory we've grown by bootstrapping
and using our current tools and data to
build the next set of products and
features so the question of how did we
get here is very
relevant it's how we got here that's
going to give us the data that we'll be
able to use to solve this object
tracking problem so we started off with
Alpine replay which was a smartphone app
to track your day on the ski slopes so
this was targeted towards people who ski
or snowboard regularly you can just use
your phone you open up the app which is
free we use the phone's GPS plus
accelerometer to record data throughout
the day then we take in that data
analyze it and deliver back stats that
people are interested in so we can say
things like which lifts you took which
runs you came down so you can see that
kind of thing
up here on the map we also have things
like speed how fast did you go what was
your total distance for the day
how many vertical feet did you do how
long did you spend out on the mountain
did you do anything interesting like
jumps or other tricks so this is of
interest to folks who you know maybe
they're into quantified self or they
like journaling keeping track of what
they've done over the course of a ski
season or from yet a year understanding
how often how frequently how five you
spend skiing or snowboarding people also
like this because it's bragging rights
I mean skiing is a social you know
activity right and you're probably there
with some friends or you know other
skiers or snowboarders and so this is a
way to say this is what I've been doing
where I've been how fast I've been going
so on so people like to share this kind
of stuff with their friends and family
okay so what am i doing at this point in
in tracers development I was at college
I was getting a bachelor's degree in in
math and in physics okay so the next
step for trace was to expand within
action sports so we've already got this
this snow sport component with our snow
app so we're going to add water sports
onto snow sports there's a trick here
though no one wants to take their phone
sir
so we need purpose-built waterproof
hardware so we built a sensor a tracker
and this has GPS plus a bunch of sensors
in it so we've got an accelerometer
gyroscope a magnetometer and the way
this works is that you you track your
snow or your surf session and later we
added other watersports to this by
attaching this to your equipment so
you're going to use an adhesive mount to
attach the tracker to your snowboard to
your surfboard and so this is this is
again the kind of thing for someone who
surfs regularly or who regularly hits
the ski slopes and we've built this in a
similar way by by bootstrapping on what
we had before
so for snow sports basically what we've
done is we've we've swapped out the
phone for a tracker now you get a little
bit more here because we have more
sensors so we can do some some more
things with that data but it's sort of
building on the same approach for surf
we need to measure some new things but
we're going to use the same hardware in
both cases so we have very sort of
general purpose hardware that we're
building specific software applications
for so for surfing what kinds of things
do we measure and how does this work
so if I'm going surfing I'm going to you
know pack up my car with my surfboard or
if I live close to a beach maybe just
walk down I go to the beach grab my
board attach the trace paddle out catch
some waves a couple hours later I'll
come in and and head back home so how
many waves did I catch maybe I'm
interested in that you know how long was
each wave did I travel some
extraordinary distance you know there
are there are certain surf breaks where
you can surf for over a kilometre or in
some cases maybe nearly a mile how far
did I go
how long was I up on those waves did I
paddle how long did I paddle for did I
do any kind of tricks or cool maneuvers
so figuring out this
kind of stuff that was a large part of
my job so I joined the company as we
were building hardware and getting
surfing working so it was a good fit for
the math and yep great question so the
question was does the user have to
indicate when they start and stop
surfing the short answer is no so we try
and build all of these things so that
they're very easy to use so when you
when you attach the the tracker you turn
it on then you head surf hit head out
for your surf session for your ski
session you come back in you're gonna
turn it off we're just gonna analyze all
that data and and figure it out and so
no you don't need to tell us almost
anything by design we want it to be
simple and easy to use right yeah so I
joined trace the kinds of problems they
were working on it was a good fit for a
math and physics background there's a
lot of tools that I could bring here
we're working with physical measurement
data so physics brings a a great tool
set for that
I also had some MATLAB skills from
college and at the time trace was
primarily doing it's its data work in
MATLAB so the kinds of things that I
worked on during this period of traces
history and sort of product development
were things related to the tracker so we
get a bunch of data off this we need to
clean it we need to calibrate the
sensors there's also data analysis type
work how do we ignore when someone
caught a wave can we detect that event
how do we know when someone's paddling
can we you know use various kinds of
frequency analysis to understand how how
often they take a stroke how do we know
when they've done a trick so again sort
of event detection and and measurement
there so answering these kinds of
questions for surfing and then other
water sports too we we did similar work
for wakeboarding kite boarding and kite
surfing and most of this was done in in
MATLAB
so one of the things that we found was
that people would in in addition to
sharing what they've done
people would film themselves and share
the videos so we saw an opportunity here
to gamify people's videos so for example
this is this is a snow video which I'm
good
[Music]
hope
or we've got a surfing video
[Music]
so if I just dump back a little bit
let's uh close this so you can see some
of the some of the data that we're able
to add to this experience so because we
have the sensor which you can't see here
on the surfboard
we have information like how fast
someone's going we know how far they've
traveled on this wave we can show a
graphic of where they are as they catch
that wave the time elapsed and then if
they're doing tricks we can measure
those and ensure the metrics for that as
well
great question so the question was what
do the triangles represent in the
trajectory and so that's that's was the
icon that we used for various events so
for for snow sports that'll be things
like when you went off a jump did you
get any airtime for surfing that's going
to be things like turns yeah so you can
kind of get a sense for where you are
and what you were doing in that time
yeah that was a great question so the
question was related to how do we
synchronize the video and the senses so
yes this is definitely a problem in
order to do this we do need to
synchronize the video in the census and
so we started off with baby steps so if
you record video with your phone then
that works great because phone has your
phone has access to the network
it updates time regularly and so the
time on your phone when you record a
video is pretty accurate so for some of
the videos that people were using this
was pretty straightforward we'd get
really good timing information coming in
with their video but for a lot of these
applications you want a camera that's a
bit more robust so something like an
action camera or a GoPro is favored by a
lot of people here and then since
setting the time or synchronizing the
video that becomes non-trivial and so
the the solution that we hit upon was to
make it easy to set the time on your
GoPro so we had a feature in the app
where you could open it up connected to
your GoPro and it would set the time for
you and so that that was the way that we
solve that problem in in the case of a
GoPro but yeah so this allowed us to to
gamify your first person video you know
if you wore some kind of chest mount or
a head cam or you carried a phone or
some kind of handheld mount but also
third person video so the videos we saw
here the scenario video that was a
follower camera someone is skiing behind
filming and then with the surfing video
it's actually being filmed from the
beach so we don't need
to the camera and and the tracker to be
close to each other
physical proximity is an important here
so because we're at start off we keep on
growing and changing and developing
right and so we saw an opportunity to
use the technology that we had and apply
that to team sports
we picked soccer so with soccer we're
making video the central component of
our product it's it's video a front and
center and yes there are still some
individual stats so each athlete does
get individual metrics what's one of the
things that's different here is that
we're now talking about a team and we
don't have equipment anymore so our
sensor that was designed to be you know
attached to a piece of equipment this
isn't the best form factor for someone
to actually wear so we changed the shape
of the device so instead of being around
sort of puck shape now we have something
much smaller something more matchbox
shape that you can actually strap to
yourself so players wear this they'll
attach it to their dominant leg we also
make video you know front and center
here so we're standardizing the videos
so we're providing cameras we're
providing a mounting system we're
providing a tripod and sandbags and
we're also providing us a solution for
synchronizing that video we in going
from from one tracker to many to make
that sort of easier to manage we have a
smart case that can help wrangle charge
upload all of that data so the target
audience here is youth soccer team so
we're talking about high school teams
club teams teams who don't have a lot of
money or time to pay staff to film games
there's only so much you can ask a
parent volunteer to do but these are
teams and people who would like video
it's a great coaching tool if you can
show a player what they're doing on the
field suddenly there's a lot more room
for understanding and insight there
people also like sharing we found this
before
with soccer it's no different people
want to share with their friends and
family with Grandma who lives three
states over and can't come to a soccer
game and also to share with college
recruiters so we've designed this to be
simple and easy to use and to make it
possible to do a video review on the
same day as your game which is something
that's really hard for a team with no
staff so if we take a look at what's on
offer so this is primarily video based
you can watch the whole game here if you
want we can break it down for the
further coach so the coach can go do you
so we can see you know we can give the
coach a dictaphone like app where they
can record during the game and we'll
give them back a playlist so around the
times that they recorded for players we
can break things down to so say we can
go and look at every time a particular
player interacted with the ball what
were they doing
where were they on field if you're a
player on this team you get an
individual playlist which is pretty cool
and then you can get player stats so
each player can see some of some things
related to what they were doing during
the game as well as where they were on
the field so if you're concentrating on
playing a specific position well this is
a tool you might be able to use yeah so
the question was are we tracking the
ball not with a sensor so we've
instrumented the players are usually on
one team
okay all right
is the camera moving or is that like
post-processing that you're zooming in
on different areas okay another great
question so is the camera moving no the
camera is not moving at all so we've
we've given the team two stationary
cameras that are on a tripod no one's
touching it we're not moving it at all
so this is something that I've worked on
that my team has worked on so with the
video you know we have these two
separate camera feeds that we need to
bring together so seamlessly stitching
that video together has been a project
that my team has spent a lot of time
working on zooming and panning
automatically now you know our camera
covers the entire field but that means
everything is going to be super small
we'd rather focus in on where the action
is so yeah we've spent time figuring out
where's the action how should we zoom in
on that how do we pan to follow what's
going on on the field there's also other
pieces of what's been going on here you
know we need to synchronize all twenty
trackers we need to analyze the game so
answer questions like where is the field
when was the game being played can we
find the first half start earn-in second
half start and end so we know when when
we're interested in watching we have
individual data analysis similarly took
from before but for a different spot so
running versus walking distances speeds
how long did I spend on the field where
was I on the field and then some team
data analysis too so we're interested in
questions about how do the players
interact can we say anything about
possession who has the ball at some
point in time and then there are things
that coaches like to focus on like
corner kicks or free kicks or penalty
kicks set pieces where there's an
opportunity to do something very
structured or goals how do we know when
someone's got a goal so these are the
kinds of questions that I've been
working on over the last couple of years
and then my team has been working on
okay so we've reached the present great
we've reached tonight great we're going
to build a robust object tracker so now
we have a better sense of what we have
to work with and what we have to work
with is actually pretty great so first
of all we have video we have 180 degrees
where the video that covers the soccer
field so this gives you a sense of what
that latter two looks like when we get
off the cameras so we have a left and a
right view that cover about half the
field which we can stitch together to
get the whole field so in doing so we
get some amount of relationship between
the carrot wean the cameras under store
shin how do we make this image look
nicer and so we start to get some
information about the cameras and their
calibration we also have player
locations relative to the field so we
got GPS data from the trackers that all
of the players are wearing we've
automatically detected where the field
is so we know where the players are in
relation to the field and having both of
these things together gives us this
really neat advantage so you know we
have video but we also have this ground
truth data that we can use as part of
this process and the other nice thing is
that this is an existing product we're
selling this so we have a bunch of data
to work with you know at this point we
have more than a thousand soccer games
with our existing product and more to
come okay
so let's talk more about object trackers
so we're using a video to understand an
object's location and its identity and
both of those things are important here
we string together the location and
identity to get a track that represents
where the object was throughout the
video and then the other part of this
once we've built it is going to be to
evaluate it so how good is our tracker
did we find all the objects is the
location of those objects accurate and
is the identity consistent we don't want
objects to randomly switch identities or
we don't want multiple
to be associated with the same object so
let's start with the things that we we
understand a little bit better so
evaluation I just said we have this nice
data advantage we want to track all the
athletes using the video and they're
already wearing GPS trackers so great
we've just solved our evaluation problem
we're going to compare these two
different data sources to do evaluation
the other thing that we know is that we
have a lot of stuff we have two cameras
and we get the videos off them in chunks
because that makes it easier to upload
so we have lots of videos with different
timing information we have camera
calibrations information so where are
the cameras how do we map from image
space to ground space we have twenty or
forty trackers with multiple sensors
depending on whether one team is wearing
them or both teams so here this is where
our GPS data comes in all of that has a
bunch of timing information and sampling
rates we have a field model from our
automatically detected field and we're
we're hoping we'll have some object
tracker results so all of this combined
there's a bunch of different reference
times and sampling intervals and we have
multiple spatial coordinates in various
images and on the ground so let's have
some glue let's make this easy so we're
going to use Python Python is great for
this kind of thing we have lots of
useful packages on syfy numpy for
handling data OpenCV gives us really you
know out-of-the-box tools for handling
videos and images tensorflow and other
machine learning frameworks they could
come in handy if we need a neural
network in particular we're going to
talk a little bit about object detectors
so python is very convenient for
wrapping up all of this data and so we
we can just use some of these existing
tools to to manipulate it with ease
okay so now we have data we have an
approach maybe we still need a tracker
so there's a couple of different ways
that we can approach tracking so the
first is let's say a bit more visual so
we find a person in an image or find an
object that we want to track and then we
use the appearance of that object to
understand where it goes so we're
looking at various aspects of appearance
here things like color maybe contours
shapes to understand how something moves
with our data
players are kind of small especially
when they're far from the camera and
they wear uniforms so any kind of color
information is going to be a little
harder to work with because we can't
count on everyone wearing different
clothing evaluation is also potentially
a little more difficult we have trouble
enforcing motion constraints like we
don't want our players to fly through
the air that doesn't seem like the right
sport
another approach we could take is sort
of to track people physically by
understanding their motion so with this
approach we're going to understand where
the people are in our video and then
we're going to construct tracks by using
a motion model to determine identity so
in this in this approach we understand
location quite well and it's the
identity part that we really need to
solve we can also bring into play really
simple motion models like you know based
on things like how fast can someone run
how fast can you accelerate things like
this plus it's really easy to evaluate
this we're already in ground space we
have GPS data evaluation should be
pretty straightforward so for today
we're going to go with physical tracking
all right so where we we've chosen a
tracking model the first thing we need
to know are where are the people
so it's 2019 we have some lovely object
detectors
floating around let's use one
so we can take tensorflow pi torch if we
want something to use really quickly we
can go and look at at one of the models
zoos and pick out an object detector so
with this we can just take one of our
frames run it through the object
detector to get a bunch of bounding
boxes now we know where all the people
are we have a camera calibration we can
map that two dots on the field so we've
started to solve our question about
where are the people how do we link all
of these these dots these people
together so this is a kind of question
that's related to filtering people have
applied a bunch of different approaches
here Kalman filtering you can think
about this in terms of probability or
simulations particle filters kind of
bring these together there are
approaches that involve constructing a
graph that says something about where
something could have moved and then find
find a path through the graph as well as
other approaches so we think that these
former tracks so we think our person
proceeded along in this fashion we just
need to reconstruct that so we're going
to represent these probability
distributions using particles basically
we take a bunch of particles and use
that to discretize our probability
distribution in such a way that if we
increase the number of particles and
take a histogram we get our distribution
back so particles have a location a
velocity those things are pretty
straightforward they tell us where the
particle is and how it moves they're
also going to have a weight so you know
probability paradigm here the weight is
going to be the likelihood that the
object is at that location so it's going
to depend on the distance from our our
dot so thinking in terms of
probabilities we kind of get into a
bunch of Bayesian ways of thinking but
we can also view this in terms of
simulations and sampling so if you would
prefer you can think about each particle
as a you know potential
location of the object a potential
simulation for where the object was and
we're going to take those simulations
and aggregate them to understand our
real objects motion and in this case you
can think of of weight as the kind of
quality of this simulation if the weight
is higher the simulation is good if the
weight is low we think the simulation is
is poor so how do we get from one time
step to the next so we have these
velocities let's update using this very
simple motion model let's let's pick
constant velocity and add in some noise
for good measure so to update our
particle from time step I 2 I plus 1
we're basically just going to take its
current location and add in the velocity
times the time the time step between
between our incidents in time we're
going to add in noise to the location as
well as to the velocity this is going to
account for things that are perhaps
nonlinear like acceleration so this is
all very well and good and we can sort
of understand how we move our particles
we need to make sure that they remain
within the the within our regions of
probability or close to at the object
that we actually want to track so we're
going to to sort of force the issue by
resampling these particles when required
so the way that this works is we take
our our current set of particles they
have weights we draw new particles from
the weighted distribution and then we
use this to kind of get rid of particles
that don't represent that distribution
very well so back in the simulation
paradigm we're going to keep the
simulations that are good and duplicate
them we're going to delete the bad
simulations so if we put all this
together this is this is what it looks
like we start off by initializing our
particles we can compute weights and we
can get the object's location by
aggregating over all those particles
locations so we can take a mean or do
something fancier and then in general
we're going to ask this question of
other
particles representative do they still
represent our object very well if the
answer is yes we're just going to go and
update and sort of do this shorter cycle
here as long as we can if they're not
representative we get into slightly
trickier question should we resample
these particles well maybe we don't want
to in some cases like where our object
has gone off screen we actually don't
want to continue to keep our track
around so sometimes we're going to
abandon the object but if we think we
should keep it around maybe we do need
to every sample maybe we need to
continue to keep those particles
clustered around the the locations of
our dots so we had sort of had this
larger loop that includes resampling
because resampling tends to be a little
more expensive we only want to do it
when we really have to okay so that's
one object but we have 22 players on a
soccer field so we'd better be tracking
more than one of them so how do we do
this for multiple objects multiple
people so the expedient thing to do is
to use different bunches of particles so
we're going to set up one set of
particles for each each track that we
want to follow so here for example we've
got two people say and we're going to
have two sets of particles alright so
we've built this what does it actually
look like so I'll explain what this is
and then I'll play it we have the view
front to both of our cameras so left
camera right camera and bounding boxes
around all of our players I promise this
becomes clearer as soon as I play it but
then you'll all be distracted watching
it so I'm going to explain to us we have
our tracks where were the players how do
they move and we're representing ID by
color here so different color means
different person and then we have
something to do with evaluation we're
matching it up to our GPS data and so
this this is something about how that
how that's working so
let's take a look at this
and I'll play it again because it's kind
of short
okay so we have a tracker it seems to be
kind of doing what we want I think we
still have some questions though like is
it robust how do we make it robust so if
we can understand some of the potential
issues here we have a better you know a
sense of the kinds of things that we
might need to look for here so first of
all who are we tracking we want to be
tracking the athletes the soccer players
on the team as they're running around
the field but there's more people than
just players in these videos we have
referees we have spectators we have
players who are currently off the field
so you know how do we get rid of some of
these people that were not interested in
so much we have this this model of a
field we know where people are relative
to the ground so maybe we can use this
we can exclude people who are further
away from the field who are outside the
edges of the field that should take care
of most of the spectators right what
about referees that's that's going to be
a hotter problem I mean they're running
around the field just like the players
are maybe we need some some different
tools to take on referees we also want
to know something about what are the
people doing you know this is video of a
soccer game so we've got two teams we've
got a ball they interact you know people
there's you know people are try to steal
the ball they tackle each other
we've got corner kicks or free kicks
where there's a lot of players close by
we've got people trying to intercept and
you know steal a ball or take a ball
from someone so there's a there's a few
different things that we want to make
sure we handle here firstly occlusions
we have a single camera perspective so
if someone's standing behind someone
else relative to the camera
we may not be able to see them we may
not know that they're there this could
be brief you know maybe two players just
pass each other or it could be extended
if everyone's standing right next to
each other
attempt to prevent this corner kick from
from becoming a goal maybe we have 20
players who are including each other
that's complicated
this is youth soccer so substitutions
happen
kids aren't expected to play for the
whole of the game and in fact in many
cases it's expected that they won't
team's some teams place an emphasis on
everyone playing for a similar amount of
time and so we want to be able to handle
that so we wanted to handle people
coming on starting a new track
people coming off ending that track and
then the last thing that we we want to
understand is how well do we do we know
where the athletes are so we've got
video with bounding boxes and there
could be some difference in where that
bounding box is located which would
translate to a difference in where that
dot appears on the field we've got a
camera calibration or a field model that
we've done some amount of like
automatically detecting or fitting maybe
those don't quite line up with with what
we see in the video and what we have on
the ground finally when we come to
evaluate we're using commercial GPS
technology which has an accuracy of
about five to ten meters so our ground
truth data also has some inaccuracies
and some tolerance that we need to be
aware of here
so how do we actually address these
issues so the first thing and the most
important thing is to understand the
trackers performance so we need to
evaluate it against the GPS data to
understand what's going on this will let
us answer questions like did we track
all the players do we have a consistent
understanding of identity you know if we
start off tracking player a do they
continue to be player a so that's that's
the first thing
nextly we have a bunch of parameters so
we can tune them right we can use some
you know we can set up some kind of cost
using our evaluation we can then do a
variety of different things here we
could learn some parameters we could fit
some parameters at the very least we
could sample some different parameters
and see what works maybe we need some
improvements through our tracker model
maybe it's not handling certain
situations properly and then there's a
variety of other things that we could
bring into play so we talked a little
bit about appearance models maybe
knowing which team a player is on based
on the color of their jersey turns out
to be important maybe we need to improve
evaluation there's lots of different
things here and in general it's a work
in progress the kind of thing that you
need contacts to understand so what is
this going to be used for one of the
requirements in general this is beyond
the scope and the time limit of this
talk so I think this is a cool problem
to work on and I hope you agree it's
sort of interesting from a data
perspective there's a bunch of cool
Python tools we can use here but why why
do we care so because we can because we
can do this we have the data we have you
know a thousand plus soccer games and
Counting and it's it's something that we
can use you know that trace is
interested to differentiate itself we
can you also use this to improve our
current soccer product so making it
easier to understand what you're looking
at so back when we looked at the the
player Clips okay if I'm the player I
know who I am but what if I send it to
someone else how do they pick me out
amongst a team of you know my teammates
or wearing the same clothes as I am so
if we can highlight the relevant player
that makes it easier to use and easier
to share we can we can potentially build
new products that are simpler we've just
given twenty trackers to a group of high
school aged students and there they need
to manage that in a busy noisy
environment right before a soccer game
what if they didn't have to do that what
if we could do this without needing
trackers that would make everyone's life
easier it also opens opens up
opportunities for us right now we're
reliant on GPS which works outdoors so
if we don't need that in anymore can we
go indoors maybe this opens up other
sports
two days but I think whatever we choose
to do sorry we're going to be focusing
on continuing to build products that are
simple that are easy to use that you can
understand quickly and we'll be doing
this in a way that that leverages what
we currently have in terms of data and
in terms of technology bootstrapping our
way to the next product and feature
[Applause]
basically you're doing this this cuz the
gps precision so forth
he mentioned five to ten meters the GPS
I thought GPS is got changed you know
the military in this country gave up
some of their restrictions some years
ago like five or six are genuine and the
GPS was it was okay there's a couple of
parts of that question so I will I will
answer them sequentially firstly there
was a question about GPS technology and
its accuracy and whether military-grade
technology had better accuracy than this
the answer to that is yes there is
military-grade GPS technology that is
highly accurate the consumer grade
technology that we're using is not we're
using components that are substantially
cheaper and so there's trade-offs there
between price and and the accuracy that
you can get and so yes we're probably
not using the most accurate GPS
technology but we're using something
that we found to be adequate for the
kinds of applications that we're
building so I hope that answered the
first part of your question the second
part was is it because of the GPS
inaccuracies that way using a
probabilistic particle based tracking
approach nor is the short answer
I've been talking about this tonight
because it's approach that's pretty
robust its quick to explain and to setup
and it's fairly powerful and the GPS
inaccuracies come into play more when we
start talking about evaluation rather
than tracking in in the sort of pure
tracking part of this problem we have
more issues with the clarity of our
video or how well we understand the
cameras location and orientation so yes
we do have to compensate for GPS but
that's not why we've chosen this
approach
have you thought about other sports like
American football a lot of practices
like high school coaches to actress sort
of a camera to vary its position so if
you build study afterwards
to be a great application
yes so the question was how we thought
about all the sports and particularly
American football to paraphrase
yes we have thought about all the sports
right now we have enough on our plate
with soccer American football would be
interesting right yeah it right now it's
a question of bandwidth honestly great
question so we have these bunch of
particles they have speeds and locations
the question was how do we cope for
changes in direction so the the model
that we pick tonight was constant
velocity but you'll recall we also added
some noise and so the noise in general
allows us to compensate for
nonlinearities acceleration and changes
in direction things like this we also
make sure that it does that by
resampling the particles so at each step
we're asking does this particle continue
to represent the object and if not we're
going to replace it by something that
does better and so overall our cloud of
particles is going to follow the object
even if individual particles don't and
so having that that randomness that
variation in our set of particles is
important because we want some of the
particles to end up near where the
object is at the next point in time so
yes we could take we could have a higher
order model we could include
accelerations or we could rephrase this
in terms of directions and speeds
instead of velocities I think in general
it's best to start with the simplest
thing and add complexity when you need
it
how now that the products being used by
people would have a large set of data
that you know is useful and this sort of
work that you're trying to do but when
you first started what was the thought
process that you put into what you
gather in the first place given that you
were trying something new okay great
question so looking back we have this
nice data set of video plus sensor data
that we can use for this problem but
obviously well the question is do we
have that foresight or if not how did we
get this is that okay so yes at the
beginning we did not think we would
necessarily get here
however we used tools and technologies
that we already had
so we took a sensor that we had
developed that we knew how to use that
when you worked and then we instrumented
the players because that was that was
something similar to what we've done
before previously a surfer would put
this on their equipment now we're having
a soccer player wear it with the with
the cameras I mean originally we did
start from footage of that you know
somewhere where you have a human
operator who focuses the camera on the
action and that's all very well and good
and and it produces very nice quality
film but it's it didn't meet the ease of
use and the kinds of cost parameters
around the target audience so we were
looking for something that is that
requires as little of of your time as
possible as well as users things that
are not too difficult to sort of put
together we want we want to keep the
price point affordable for a youth
soccer team and so the combination of
those meant that paying someone to film
was too expensive and so having a
stationary camera is a good solution for
that if we can do it with a stationary
camera it's easier and it's cheaper
so it's serendipitous absolutely but I
think we got there for
[Music]
[Music]
yes so this is a great question which is
we have this bunch of particles that we
want to represent an object and then we
resample them based on the location of
some object how do we know it's the
right one or how do we know that there's
an object there we kind of get into this
circular reasoning so I'm gonna go back
for a diagram okay so the short answer
is that we want we want the particles to
do the work of linking things up and
we're going to make sure that the
particles are close to an object that's
reasonable so we're going to do some
kind of Association here when we compute
weights we're just going to care is it
close to an object rather than a
specific object and then when we think
about particles as a whole and some of
the other questions of resampling then
we're going to get into issues of
uniqueness so you know in this situation
where we have tracks that cross we could
you know one on one solution here is to
just join them up straight how do we
know that's a great question you know
we'd be relying on cues like velocity
and and this is this is a situation
where it's likely you'll need to spend a
bunch of time making sure your tracker
is going to produce the right answer so
we're going to control part of it by
making sure that our cloud of particles
has sufficiently high weights those
weights are going to be computed based
on how close the particle is to any
object and then we're going to look at
the cloud of particles as a whole and
decide whether to keep it or not based
on maybe some uniqueness
criteria may be some proximity to two
objects and things like that
so yes definitely a problem definitely
something that the model needs to be you
know that needs to be thought about in
terms of the model so with that a lot of
great questions a lot of great
discussions and I welcome you to come
join hair afterwards and ask a question
but let's thank them for a great talk
[Applause]